Nos dicen: "Laila coloca una serie de luces
desde el suelo hasta la parte superior del
marco de una puerta que tiene 2.5 metros de
altura. Luego baja el resto de la serie en
línea recta hasta un punto en el suelo
que está a 6 metros de distancia de la
base del marco de la puerta. Si en
cada metro de la serie hay 10 luces,
¿cuántas luces en total hay en la serie?
Pausa el video e inténtalo por tu cuenta.
Muy bien, vamos a trabajar juntos. Creo que
este problema necesita algún tipo de dibujo
para visualizarlo mejor, así que dibujemos el
marco de la puerta justo así, y este marco mide
2.5 m de altura, esta es su altura, y lo que hace
Laila es colocar esta serie de luces, que vamos a
pintar de color amarillo, que va desde la base
hasta la parte superior del marco de la puerta;
y luego baja el resto de la serie en línea recta
hasta un punto en el suelo que está a 6 m de
distancia de la base del marco de la puerta, así
que mostremos un punto que esté a 6 m de la base
del marco de la puerta, se va a ver así: esta
distancia que tenemos aquí es de 6 m. Entonces,
Laila colocó el resto de la serie de luces
desde la parte superior del marco de la puerta
hasta este punto que está a 6 m de la base de la
puerta. Recuerda que estamos pintando de color
amarillo la serie de luz. Ahora bien, nos piden
que encontremos cuántas luces en total hay en la
serie, entonces la forma en la que podemos hacerlo
es, primero, encontrar la longitud de la serie de
luces, y para encontrar eso necesitaremos sumar
2.5 m más la longitud de la hipotenusa de este
triángulo rectángulo. Creo que debemos suponer
que esta es una casa estándar, donde los marcos
de la puerta forman un ángulo de 90° con el piso.
Entonces necesitamos encontrar la longitud de
esta hipotenusa ya que al sumarla con estos 2.5 m
podremos saber la longitud de la serie de luces.
Después simplemente habrá que multiplicar por 10
porque hay 10 luces por metro de la serie, así que
hagámoslo. ¿Cómo encontramos la hipotenusa? Claro,
vamos a utilizar el Teorema de Pitágoras. Llamemos
a esto h, por hipotenusa, y sabemos que la h²
= (2.5)² + (6)², esto será igual a 6.25 + 36,
que es igual a 42.25; o bien, podemos decir que
la hipotenusa es igual a la √42.25. Y, bueno,
podríamos sacar la calculadora en estos momentos,
pero quiero que sigamos usando esta expresión para
encontrar el número de luces totales. Entonces,
¿cuál es la longitud total de la serie? Hay
que tener cuidado por aquí, muchas personas
podrán decir "Oh, ya encontramos la hipotenusa,
ahora multipliquemos eso por 10". De hecho, mi
mente casi hace eso justo ahora, sin embargo,
tenemos que darnos cuenta que la serie completa
es la suma de la hipotenusa más estos 2.5,
entonces la longitud total de la serie de
luces es igual 2.5 + √42.25. Y, de nuevo,
para obtener el número total de luces en la serie,
hay que multiplicar esta cantidad por 10, así que
es momento de sacar la calculadora. Tenemos 42.25,
a esto le calculamos su raíz cuadrada, que nos
da 6.5, y a esto le sumaremos los otros 2.5 m.
Esta es la longitud total de la serie de luces,
así que la serie completa de luces mide 9 m, y
esto lo multiplicaremos por 10 luces por metro,
entonces el número de luces es igual a 9 m de la
serie completa por 10 luces por metro, lo que nos
dará un total de 90 luces. Ahora, algunos de ustedes
pueden debatir -si piensas muy profundamente en
esto- que si tenemos una luz justo al comienzo,
si esto fuera algún tipo de configuración como
el poste de una cerca, entonces podrían argumentar
que hay una luz extra, pero para efectos de este
problema podemos pensar que este es un promedio
del número de luces, un promedio de 10 luces por
metro; entonces si la longitud de la serie es de 9
m, al multiplicar 9 x 10 nos da 90 luces en total.